he's mr. Hollywood knees Rich Eisen NFL
Network host and host of the Rich Eisen
show on DirecTV favorite movie ending
rich is oh god you're by the way you
guys are spoiler alert potential right
now how many how many movies did you
just ruin four people in the last two
minutes of the conversation okay
isn't there a time frame here rich isn't
there a statute of limitations on when
I'm allowed to break the news to you
that you know what DiCaprio did not he
dies in Titanic I mean you're just a
bull in a china shop right here I think
you're I think you're stalling here cuz
you don't have a great ending no no no
no no Chinatown is one of the best guy
thinks is a movie that pulls everything
together yeah if you want to talk about
jacketing greatness yeah but but even
that right now I mean there are some
people you know there are some
Millennials that listen to the Dan
Patrick show for whom Chinatown they
hear is talking about oh I gotta check
it out yeah if I tell you the actual
ending right now I mean that really does
spoil the whole damn thing I mean but it
is a great ending here's one that
probably nobody's mentioned like a great
ending that you didn't expect to hang
over the last when the credits are
rolling and you look at the photographs
that they've taken throughout the entire
movie I that's one of my favorite
endings of all time I didn't see it
coming and you just sit there and it it
pulls the whole movie together in a way
that you wouldn't even imagine it would
attempt that's a grill of the ender
hangover yeah that's a great choice
there yeah nobody brought that up but
but you're not spoiling you're not
spoiling it that's the king that's why I
bring the next levels you know what I
mean I'm just saying the is Jerry Jones
a conversation tonight as you get ready
for my I just got whiplash
with that transition
I tried to sneak it in on your Ridge
look over here we are going you're going
to actually reenact what might be going
down an illegal aspect between the
commissioner and Jerry Jones with the
cast of The Hangover that's gonna be a
fantastic ending it's gonna be working
we're gonna end it on NBC with Liam
McHugh tossing to the piece of tape I
don't know is the short answer to that
question I don't know if that is of a
major interest right now people who are
tuning in to see whether the Seahawks
can rebound from their loss to
Washington and Arizona put their foot in
the ground at four and four start
basically anew and make a run to the
playoffs with two all-time greats whose
windows of opportunity and their careers
are closing I don't know if you know
we're gonna sit around and bat around
whether Jerry Jones is so pissed at the
commissioner about Ezekiel Elliott that
he's gonna sue him who would you rather
interview tonight Jerry Jones or the
Commissioner Oh Jerry
oh gosh one of my oh gosh yes
I mean I've interviewed Jerry Jones and
on the air live and so many different
situations from the Superdome and New
Orleans when the Cowboys season was on
the line if you remember when New
Orleans was undefeated this was their
their Super Bowl season which they lost
their final three games of the year and
still won the Super Bowl but Dallas with
Wade Phillips came into that building
and Jerry came on before the game and
called himself nervous as a cat because
he knew that if they lost this game the
season would be over and he might have
to blow the whole team up which he did
in the middle of the next season anyway
with Wade Phillips and that was just him
being flat-out honest wearing it all on
his sleeve and then I interviewed him
with the rest of gameday morning about
two hours before kickoff of the Super
Bowl in AT&T Stadium where everything
that interview was hunky-dory about how
great everything was in Dallas at the
time they were already finding out
certain sections of the stadium didn't
meet fire code and he had no idea with
all of that and he had the biggest smile
on his face I mean he is just a
fascinating interview whenever he sat
down on live TV on the Anusol network so
I would choose him who's more powerful
in the NFL the Commissioner or Jerry
Jones mm-hmm I guess we'll find out huh
yes we will
we're talking to Rich Eisen from the NFL
Network tonight it'll be the Seahawks
against the Cardinals sell it here we go
we got now you already sold Larry
Fitzgerald and we got Adrian Peterson
yeah against that yes I mean yes correct
I mean with the Rams in first place
sitting at home with Tom Savage walking
into their building on Sunday you have
to keep pace with the Los Angeles Rams
which is a statement that if I had told
you back in week one would come across
as sarcastic or ironic hmm but this is
fact and an Adrian Peterson and Larry
Fitzgerald this is something that
they've been dreaming up for a long time
at playing with one another I mean the
Cardinals had an opportunity to draft
Peterson and Pat and and the executive
who was overruled in the room at the
time of the draft is now the general
manager here in Arizona Steve Coble got
them together hmm they're four and four
and they have an opportunity to make a
run here and if it if it doesn't happen
start tonight you have to think it
doesn't happen at all and then there's
the Seahawks who you're still wondering
if they have the Super Bowl in them and
of course they walk into this building
tonight where I prefer to say if it is
short yardage situation on the goal line
and will be interesting to see what the
play call is so there's a lot of
intrigue involving tonight I'm assuming
that the Seahawks it took a little you
know it's a 30 second promo and you went
in about 90 seconds
by the way I didn't I didn't get a count
in my ears I'm assuming the Seahawks are
trailing with five minutes to go right
that
that's always the way it is that's how
Pete Carril scripts it so then Russell
Wilson jr. the third can somehow somehow
try to keep that offense alive afloat
yes you don't don't forget to break down
and protection that that's always a
hallmark as well as situations and the
running game might not be might not be
working right Freeney back in this
building you know you played for the
team these are just bits now I'm just
don't nuggets out okay but and it's on
NBC on the peacock yes yes it is I'll be
watching now there's a pre and then
there's a pre right I'll be doing the
pre the pre pre and then I'm part of the
pre then I'll be on a half time with
your guys Tony and Rodney yeah and then
I'm on post got all working well got it
all but I don't want to spoil the end I
don't want to spoil the end Dan what if
sports was scripted and we didn't know
it that is that is is that by the way
not the mantra of every sports gambler
yes right there yeah they think that for
some reason that it's like everybody
goes to Buffalo Wild Wings and then you
decide like eh like we're gonna put in
we're gonna bring that back yeah we got
a little machine here yeah
all right well we'll be watching tonight
beautiful yeah excellent thank you for
your mr. DP thank you miss hey you're a
better man to fill in for me you're the
you're the right man to fill in for me I
didn't know these your shoes that I'm
stepping into tonight is that right I
think this I mean I think that's the
price you do one Thursday right you do
the one that's a start a big one yeah
the big one menu then then you tap the
top of the helmet you can all want to be
like VP yeah I I wish I could be there
but I'm glad I'm not I love watching
Thursday Night Football
just doesn't just know when you're doing
that at some point when you're looking
into the camera I've got a glass of wine
and I've got a cigar and I got my feet
up and I'm watching just just to let you
know I got my Snuggie on and I got my
foot ease and I'm just having a damn
good time there just to let you know I'm
there in spirit all right thank you all
right that's Rich Eisen NFL Network host
and the Rich Eisen show as well for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]